one of the most volatile relationships
that we have going on right now is
between us
and bitcoin
bitcoin bitcoin has its good days they
have their bad days and there's days
you're like
baby i don't even recognize you anymore
i don't even know you anymore okay
so our next store will help you form a
relationship with crypto without having
to go steady okay so here's the advice
from the motley fool again our friends
of the motley fool we respect what they
do
um
how to invest in cryptocurrency without
actually investing in cryptocurrency
seems a little backwards yeah this is
the one well let's unpack this mother
sucker right how to invest in crypto
without actually having to invest in
criminals okay exactly so you can gain
exposure
to the crypto market for our friends out
there without actually having to buy the
tokens themselves by investing
in
crypto stocks what does that mean
cryptostock is a company that is somehow
involved in the cryptocurrency movement
here are a couple examples
excuse me number one
i got choked up again talk crypto
i gotta talk crypto it's volatile i've
had an up and down relationship but i'm
gonna be all right so here are a couple
examples number one probably the most
famous example out there is tesla we all
know tesla tesla invested 1.5 billion
dollars into bitcoin earlier this year
we all know that their ceo elon musk has
he's famously supported dogecoin and
he's in on bitcoin he's out on bitcoin
the the crypto community loves them and
they hates them it's very volatile but
basically tesla has invested in crypto
so if you're investing in tesla right
it's almost like
adversely you know inadvertently you're
you're investing
into bitcoin number two square square
was founded by jack dorsey jack dorsey
is a huge proponent of crypto square is
a digital payments company that is
growing rapidly and has also invested
heavily in bitcoin
this allows its merchants to accept
various types of cryptocurrency as a
form of payment so that's square number
three on this list is a company called
nvidia
nvidia if you haven't heard about them
they basically help create all the
computer chips that are in your gaming
devices right so they they what they do
is computer graphics processing units
called gpus we're doing a lot of
use stuff today duis tuis gpus basically
they're basically widely used in
cryptocurrency so here's the bottom line
there's a three companies that you can
invest in without actually having to go
all in on bitcoin or dogecoin or
ethereum or any cryptocurrency out there
so the article basically goes on to say
if you see a ceo or a company that's
getting behind crypto you can use them
as you're sort of like guinea pig right
to not have to dive in immediately and
still you can still get a piece of the
rewards respect so none of these
companies focus exclusively on crypto i
think we can all agree on that tesla
electric vehicles
square digital payments nvidia computer
chips but basically they factor it you
know it's a factor in their business
okay so if cryptocurrency does take off
someday and becomes widely accepted
which still remains to be seen
um these organizations would clearly
benefit from from it and if you invested
in these stocks so will you last thing
by investing in these stocks you may
also benefit from cryptocurrency success
without facing the risks of buying
crypts so you're basically getting some
of the reward without taking all the
risk all right life's all about balance
risk versus reward right you eat too
much you're going to get fat drink too
much you're going to be drunk but you're
not going to not eat not going to not
drink you got to have balance right
right so there's some people that are
all in on crypto i've interviewed people
on crypto like how much of your net
worth is crypto 100 bro i don't even do
cash anymore just straight crypto okay
good luck with that yes and then hey uh
you do anything with crypto no i don't
trust it one touch with a 10 foot pole
like ostrich just keep my head in the
center pretending it doesn't exist
the truth is always somewhere in the
middle right the answer is somewhere
always in the middle so i think there's
a happy medium i've been very vocal
about this
i invested i think five years ago five
percent of my liquid assets into bitcoin
not so bad i didn't under
well yeah i didn't understand bitcoin at
the point my boy's like dude
bitcoin
got to get in on it i'm like dude i
don't know what these bitty bops and
blocky chains and booty dudes
yeah okay so basically i did it and it's
worked out well for me so
don't go all in on crypto but don't just
you know be all out on crypto that's my
advice for you and if you're still not
sure about investing in crypto you can
take advantage of investing in these
crypto stock companies
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken